well john lydon aka johnny rotten knows
a thing or two about being uncensored
and that's why he's back for another
installment of johnny's rotten world and
he joins me now live from the cotswolds
in england i have to say john you look
like a a real member of the landed
british gentry there
i'm proper and i'm in the middle of
recording so
you know if you're going to respect your
music dress appropriately
how are you pierce i'm good thanks john
great to have you back a lot of stuff
going on i want to talk to you about
i'll tell you the first one that struck
me
as the man that gave us anarchy in the
uk what do you make of this attempt by
scotland to force another referendum and
break away from the uk and it comes at a
time where many people think a united
ireland might then follow we may see the
end of the united kingdom how do you
feel about that
it's it swings around about some
political trickery and i i'm unimpressed
by all of them and they have been for
many many
a decade uh and particularly that that
that scottish lady uh i think she's
highly deceitful and she's going to
cause some serious problems down the
line
would you be sad we didn't build
hadrian's wall
[Laughter]
would you be sad would you be sad to see
scotland go off on its own
no because have you ever tried spending
scottish money in england
[Laughter]
it's not easy
no it ain't it's not easy finding that's
got to spend any money period our gigs
there are some of the best uh and finest
we've ever done
to me these are my people
and uh the political shenanigans and the
divisiveness is like i think ultimately
relevant and a
fiasco all backfire on them it always
does and if it doesn't i'll be there to
make sure it will
we had uh
nicola sturgeon milady you talked about
the leader of the snp in scotland she
met the queen today it must have been a
pretty difficult conversation i would
imagine and it came as uh prince charles
uh let it be known he would no longer be
accepting bags of cash for his charities
after three million years heroes were
stuffed in fortnight mason bags yeah
what did you make of that
well i reckon all right well done
charlie you've joined the working class
have you ever had three million stuffed
in a thornton mason's bag
no i i heard yesterday it was one
million and these figures are going to
juxta position up and down and
infinitely i don't know what that's
about
personally i think it's really none of
my business right well did yeah i mean i
suppose the argument is until it's
proved
i mean the argument is true
yeah i mean the argument is that he's
the future king the king is very much
all of our business in the sense that we
pay for the upkeep of the royal family
study your history pierce kings have
been collecting money like that
since the dawn of kings that is true
so should we should we care if it is all
going to the charity anyway should we
care does it matter how the charity gets
this money
well i i would
if that be the truth then i then i'm
quite happy that the millions go
tax-free to charity because one of my
biggest problems is every time i donate
i get text on it all right so i think
well done bonnie bonnie prince charlie
the scottish connection
[Laughter]
did you catch any of of glastonbury john
no
no we we almost played there they gave
us an offer but it was so underwhelming
financially that there was no point to
it i've heard there's been people
moaning there's been people moaning that
like old fellas are having fun yeah you
know
oh god's sake and it's an old fella
doing the moaning what it what is the
oldest
what is the oldest john that you think
what's the oldest you would feel
comfortable performing in front of a big
crowd
well if paul mccartney can do that
right accolades accolades right
fantastic all right i think you should
keep going and going and going like the
duracell bunny until you finally run out
it seems interesting because i watched
mccartney mccartney set i thought was
actually really good mainly because his
back catalog of songs is so incredible
but also i think he's he's been quite
careful about the kind of song he sings
so that his voice doesn't get exposed
because obviously not as strong as it
was when he was you know in his 30s but
diana ross i felt sadly
she's got some great songs obviously
she's two years younger than mccartney
but actually watching it on tv at home i
thought her voice was was pretty awful
what do we do with what do we do with
icons she's lost it she's lost in a
chorus of backing vocalists yeah
and that's kind of grim but i don't care
i absolutely grew up and loved diana
ross yeah deaf right does it matter
does it matter that you don't care for
the same level rattle
the only one i'd knock is mick jagger
because he's rubbish
well you know what i had this debate i
had this debate the other day about mick
jagger because i don't think he's ever
been a very good singer he's a great
rock star performer and a great dancer
but i don't think he's a great singer is
he
he must have connections man to get away
with that for so long
hello i mean i've i've been criticized
as not being a great singer but my
classic example by way of explanation is
well neither is that right
is it something like that i don't know
you know that's what you get when you
hang out with you know the elite i got
fair play to him and all that but it's
uh there is no such thing as old codgers
right there's just people wanting fun at
any age right don't let governments
dictate to you what time you should give
up and collect your pension
and those are the kind of rules that
lefty fools follow not us proper people
do you think do you think we should all
you've got to you've got to you've got
to kick the donkey to the bitter end i
sort of i do agree with you i mean i
sort of do believe in the philosophy of
growing old disgracefully because why
wouldn't you
who wants to grow old boring leaders and
you know yeah behaving yourself i've yes
i remember when i was young i used to
think like how great it would be if i
got put in an old folks home imagine a
terror i could get up
when you go around let me go around john
with all the hype around the sex pistols
series has come out and everything and
obviously he's put the pistols back in
all the headlines and stuff what kind of
reaction do you get from from the
british public these days
oh very very favorable and pro-me
because they know i was the man what
wrote the songs created the image
performed it live and had to live with
the experience whereas this bunch of
fake wannabes are nothing like that and
it's quite laughable really um that that
pill gigs now what it used to be pistols
audience are now fully fully and wrapped
around us right they know this is
nonsense this should never have happened
man how can you cut out the songwriter i
think you're going to do anything at all
to make the world a better place
i i'd completely agree the pistols
without you is just not the pistols what
do you make john of the at the strikes
that are going on at the moment in this
country with a lot of different
companies now little different unions
wanting to take on the companies at a
time when we're already in a pretty
serious financial situation do you
support the strikers
yeah no i don't did six or one half a
dozen of the others some of those
strikes actually seriously affected us
on tour
our tour bus kept breaking down so we'd
have to find alternative means of
transport and one of them would of
course be trains oh no the trains are on
strike it seems like england has this
this perpetual motion of self destroying
itself just when it could be saved and
that's how i view strikes as as
unnecessary if you don't like the job
sod off and get another one all right
but trains keep the country running i
can't i can't change that that's an
actual fact i mean we're seeing well
we're saying i think the royal mail gets
anybody
yeah i mean the royal mail voted today
to go on strike as well we're seeing the
airline uh cruise now wanted to do the
same it's sort of spreading like like a
virus which ironic
given that we just come out of a
pandemic or still coming out of it
involving a real virus but i just feel
like everyone now is just trying to
you know exploit the situation to me
yeah yeah i'm very worried that it's the
same people
behind all of these orchestrated
maneuvers it really is just all about
destroying everything
and this secret agenda karl marx
nonsense i mean my god man young kids
are supporting a professional parasite
as a political doctrine
and here we go i i was watching some of
the union officials the other morning on
tv
and a blather out of it it was so 50
years ago didn't work stop it grow up
move on fix it
sick of them
you know what john i'm sick of them i
don't disagree i think the timing of all
this it could not be worse just when the
country is getting back on his feet it's
wyoming i think it's celebrate we're
flattened i think
yeah it's exploiting the situation yeah
before we let you go john um a little
bit of good news here i wanted you to
join me in embracing and celebrating
this so there's a cricket team
called the motley crew which i thought
you would like not the actual motley
crew that you know this is a cricket
team called the motley crew in favishim
and kent formed 29 years ago in 1993
they have been the most useless cricket
team in the history of cricket they've
never ever ever won a game until
sunday
and on sunday they finally wrote the
habit of their entire life
they chased down 140 34 against a team
from the three horseshoes pub in nearby
hearn hill they had a one wicket win and
the all-rounder bobby dolan said i
didn't think this day would ever come
but to be fair we sneaked one net
session in on wednesday they celebrated
their momentous win by toasting their
crestfallen opponents but i just think
i'm a massive cricket fan but this is so
english isn't it
this team of perennial losers and they
finally win a game what do you make of
that
oh i think that's like very good i'm
really happy for them right but honestly
pierce i hate cricket
you can't hate me
you'll lose all the time you cannot hate
cricket if you hate cricket you hate
life motley crue huh i hope they don't
get done for copyright over the name
well they might won't they they might i
think they spell it a bit i think this
is that you know you know what american
lawyers are like i've just had to deal
with disney world
out of interest have you ever been
partying with motley crue john
i i i know a few of them yeah they're
all right they are they're good
we're not quite like what we're supposed
to be according to the tabloids
actually sometimes we're worse
[Laughter]
i actually can't go into details but i
interview him a survivor i interviewed
them at the whiskey go go in sunset
boulevard and they changed the awning
outside to for one night only motley
crew and piers morgan and it was
actually probably the greatest moment of
my life
it was great i hope you got that in your
bedroom i have i've got it on the loo
wall actually uh john i've got to leave
it there it's great
you've got two motley cruise in your
house
john lyon great
yes
take care all the best over and out
you